There's no Peter Parker or Miles Morales in
the trailer for "Madame Web," but plenty of
other Spider-People appear.
Who are they, and how close are their costumes
to their comics counterparts?
Fans of Sony's Spider-Man universe have had
to do some waiting this year, as the release
date for "Kraven the Hunter" was pushed back
from October 2023 to August 2024.
But they at least got the trailer for "Madame
Web," yet another adaptation of a classic
"Spider-Man" character from the studio.
The 2024 feature will star Dakota Johnson
as the clairvoyant title character.
It seems as though she will find herself protecting
a new generation of Spider-heroes in three
young women: Julia Carpenter played by Sydney
Sweeney, Mattie Franklin played by Celeste
O'Connor, and Anya Corazon played by Isabella
Merced.
"I can see the future.
Oh!
What the hell?"
"She didn't see that coming."
"That's not how it works."
Perhaps due to their connection to one another
and the wider web of Spider-people, these
soon-to-be Spider-Women must survive being
hunted by Ezekiel Sims, a deadly operator
with as-of-yet unknown motivations-- played
by Tahir Rahim.
Ezekiel Sims is the odd-spider-out in the
trailer — and that's not just because he's
trying to kill everyone else.
The character wears a chilling black-and-red
suit that is a far cry from the character's
comics attire.
In the comics, Sims has powers almost identical
to those of Peter Parker, but received them
long before as part of an ancient ritual.
Instead of becoming a superhero, he became
an immensely powerful businessman who would
use his powers sparingly.
So the comics version of Ezekiel doesn't really
have a costume in the traditional sense.
In one alternate universe, Sims steals a costume
from a variant of Spider-Man that was killed
by Morlun, one of the Inheritors, who is basically
an energy vampire.
Ezekiel's typical comics apparel doesn't appear
to have influenced his "Madame Web" look,
probably at least in part due to a casually
dressed villain cutting in on action figure sales.
"Euphoria" star Sydney Sweeney will make her
superhero debut with "Madame Web," playing
the seemingly bookish Julia Carpenter.
In the comics, she has adopted the monikers
Spider-Woman, Arachne, and even Madame Web,
all after someone else had those names.
It appears as though Sweeney will be sporting
the original black-and-white bodysuit Carpenter
wore when she first debuted in the first "Secret
Wars" series in 1984.
The design of this costume — especially
its sprawling, white insignia — will likely
remind fans of another character: Venom.
Unlike Peter Parker's symbiote suit that became
Venom, there's nothing alien about Carpenter's outfit.
Carpenter's suit actually debuted the issue
before Parker's did, and it's stated that
the now-iconic white symbiote spider symbol
was subconsciously inspired by her design.
It would be a clever twist if Sony adapted
this story beat, and allowed Tom Hardy's Eddie
Brock to finally adopt the emblem after seeing
Sweeney's Carpenter in action.
"Why would I do that?"
Anya Corazon was first introduced in a 2004
issue of "Amazing Fantasy" as the superhero Araña.
She has two main comics costume styles, one
of which includes the large, bug-eyed goggles
seen for a brief moment in the trailer.
Her first costume is a relatively casual/tactical
outfit that consists of a vest, tank top,
and jeans, all of which fit a red, black,
and yellow color motif.
After meeting Julia Carpenter, Corazon is
given a black bodysuit with white accents
very similar to her new friend's.
Under the new alias "Spider-Girl," Corazon
wears this black-and-white suit through several
minor alterations until it is destroyed by
the supervillain Vermin, at which point she
returns to something closer to her original
look.
Based on the very brief look at Corazon's
costume in the "Madame Web" trailer, it appears
as though she'll be wearing something closer
to her second costume, but with the goggles
from the first.
Unlike her friends' black costumes, Mattie
Franklin wears the traditional blue-and-red
colors of Peter Parker's Spider-Man.
That may be a nod to her uniquely close comics
connection to the original Web-Slinger.
After getting super powers in the mystical
"Gathering of Five" ceremony organized by
Norman Osborn, Mattie briefly took over for
Peter as Spider-Man while he was temporarily retired.
After Peter put the webs back on, she became
the third Spider-Woman.
Her infatuation with Peter created some bizarre
friction between them, though we don't expect
that to play into her role in "Madame Web."
That's because lots of signs point to "Madame
Web" being a prequel of sorts.
A popular theory online speculates, and his
IMDb credits indicate, that Adam Scott's suspiciously
unnamed character is actually a young Ben
Parker — Peter's uncle, who dies in most
versions of his origin story.
That'd mean "Madame Web" takes place well
before any other "Spider-Man" story, and Franklin
couldn't have any connection to the most famous
wallcrawler around.
Fans will have to wait and see when "Madame
Web" debuts on February 14, 2024.